-The bite is a gift.
-I don't want it.
Naked.
I'm so not buying your
threats anymore.
Oh my god, okay.
What the hell, the Stiles.
How about you tell me
everything.
It's my house,
my rules, buddy.
Please, where'd it go?
I thought you were psychic.
Well, dad, there's a
conversation we--
You're not gay.
No Stiles.
-What, no Stiles?
-No Stiles!
No lacrosse, no popularity,
no girlfriend.
Is there a reason the gun
is still pointed at me?
Become an alpha
by killing one.
Keep your dirty little hands
to your dirty little selves.
A banshee.
You didn't hear that?
I have no idea why that
would be in your loft.
You sound just like a cop.
I'm a thousand years old,
you can't kill me.
Someone ask her if
she's ever played lacrosse.
You're gonna be good
at this.
Are you kidding?
Okay,
that's kind of terrifying.
Drop it!
I heard you almost
got killed.
I hear you almost
For our first real date...
it's a start.
You don't remember me,
do you?
You're a werewolf.
He almost killed you too.
And we're both
still alive, see.
I'm having an asthma attack.
Someone?
Our hands are a little
bloody sometimes.
Some of us are human.
What the hell was that?
We've got a theory.
Just a slightly
terrifying theory.
I'm not done with her yet.
You said you could help him.
Guarantee your place
as an alpha.
Why don't you tell me
your name?
-Will you forget me?
-I won't.
-Kidnapper.
-I'm not a kidnapper.
You and I are doomed
to ride the storm forever.
-So if I screw up--
-You'll kill me.
Mr. Rider?
The plan is to get Stiles to
come up with a plan.
-A Stiles?
-A what?
I'm going to be fine.
-He's a hellhound.
-A dead hellhound.
He's been a step ahead of us
the whole time.
I turn into a monster
with claws and fangs.
All you have to do
is bring them out.
Who wants me?
My back.